bonjour alexis poulain merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france de
nouvelles décisions vont être prises
demain soir selon les mots à l'instance
gabriela talent le moment est venu
c'est la sémantique hier soir de jean
castex donc un confinement pour l'île de
france et je cite sur la table ça veut
dire quoi selon vous les franciliens mis
sous cloche
les week-ends la semaine les écoles
ouvertes fermées combien de temps alors
je ne suis pas devin mais clairement on
voit bien une séquence là pour préparer
l'opinion à un confinement alors que ce
soit le week-end ou la semaine on ne
sait pas mais c'est clair emmanuel
macron avait tout fait pour éviter un de
confiner et surtout l'île de france où
malgré les chiffres catastrophiques ces
derniers jours et devant l'évidence il
est obligé de revenir sur sa parole
finalement le pari qu'il a voulu faire
aller il vient de le perdre il va
falloir sans doute confiné alors avoir
évidemment vous venez de le dire est ce
que ce sera le week-end est ce que ce
sera la semaine les deux les écoles
devraient rester ouverts puisque sa part
être la ligne rouge
jean michel blanquer redisait ce serait
vraiment tout dernier et au dernier bout
de chaîne qu'on fermerait les écoles et
pourtant dans les écoles comme ailleurs
et bien le virus circule donc pourquoi
garder les écoles ouvertes si on veut
faire un confinement dur à ce moment là
ça n'a pas vraiment de sens oui et donc
et donc on est on est en train de
d'attendre comme d'habitude dans cette
phase de communication qui se répète
toujours la même des annonces à par
petit bout sans jamais d'annonce
emmanuel là qu'on le disait dans les
jours qui viennent on va devoir prendre
des décisions que voilà on le saura sans
doute demain lors de la conférence de
presse doligé vers ans et de jean castex
à la tension hospitalière ne cesse de
s'accentuer en ile-de-france le corps
hospitalière le répète depuis janvier
quand emmanuel macron vous l'avez dit
avait décidé de prendre le pari de ne
pas confiné si donc confinement il ya
ces prochains jours notamment pour
l'ile-de-france
comment est ce qu'il faudrait
interpréter
la décision de non confinement
du président en janvier février et je
crois que en janvier-février macro à
faire un choix politique celui de ne pas
écouter le corps médical qui lui
demandait un confinement au diapason
d'ailleurs des partenaires européens qui
à l'époque confinait tous dans leurs
pays respectifs pour éviter ce pic du
mois de mars dans lequel nous sommes
donc on savait que les semaines devant
nous allait amener un pic épidémique
tout ça était sur la table tout comme on
savait qu'ils allaient avoir des
variants dès le mois de septembre 2020
donc tout est écrit finalement tout
était sur la table devant mais il y à
des arbitrages politiques qui ont été
faits par le président de la république
notamment celui de ne pas confiné en
début d'année en essayant de voir si la
voie étroite qu'il essayait le pari
qu'il voulait faire pouvait éviter un
nouveau confinement parce que le
confinement s'il permet de réduire le
taux de reproduction du virus et de
lutter de manière efficace et quand même
une vie ruines pardon une mesure de la
dernière chance parce qu'on n'a pas
réussi à organiser suffisamment la
gestion des flux les gestes barrière
mais aussi les urgences l'organisation
des urgences c'est pas comme si on était
en mars 2020 on est en mars 2021
un an après le premier confinement et
pendant un an qu'est ce qui s'est passé
bien les lions continuent de fermer dans
les hôpitaux on n'a pas former davantage
de soignants la plupart d'entre eux
maintenant sont en burn out
ils ont des conditions de travail
dégradées malgré le seigneur nous on est
ici fait sur la question je voulais vous
vous posez donc il ya un franc la fin il
ya un an la france entrait pour la
première fois en confinement donc douze
mois plus tard quel est le bilan est
bien un bilan de 90 mille morts alors
certes on pourra dire que les mesures de
confinement de couvre-feu ont permis de
diminuer ce moment mais on voit bien que
le couvre-feu est une mesure qui fait qu
on a 300 morts par jour de toute façon
ces mesures de couvre-feu sont
d'ailleurs extrêmement critiquable le
confinement rappelez-vous olivier
ferrand disait en mars 2020 ou en avril
je ne sais plus que c'était pas
nécessaire puisque c'était là qu'on se
contaminaient finalement en famille on a
raté la case des du tracé détecter
isoler les tests également les vaccins
on voit le la politique vaccinale
avec ce coup d'arrêt avec astrazeneca
alors c'est aussi là le fait des
partenaires européens il a fallu se
mettre d'accord et dire on arrête en
attendant la décision demain jeudi de
l'autorité de santé européennes pour
savoir si on reprend mais la confiance
est perdue
elle était déjà difficilement gay
ni la campagne venait de commencer et là
vous dites aux français que attention
astrazeneca peut-être potentiellement
dangereux il va falloir attendre l'avis
d'une instance européenne
mais en réalité beaucoup de français
vont refuser finalement de se faire
vacciner avec astrazeneca attendant une
autre une autre potion un autre vaccin
donc on est vraiment là dans une gestion
qui montre l'attentisme la mauvaise
gestion de ces derniers mois et ce n'est
pas juste le fait de dire que c'est
pareil en italie c'est pareil en
allemagne etc
on aurait pu faire tout à fait autrement
les partenaires européens certains
d'ailleurs commence à se détacher de
bruxelles c'est le cas de l'autriche
il va investir avec israël pour un
vaccin de nouvelle génération c'est le
cas de la pologne et d'autres pays qui
vont commander des vaccins par eux mêmes
nous nous sommes coincés avec cette
politique vaccinale certes on peut
commander plusieurs marques
johnson johnson astrazeneca pfizer etc
mais les doses ne sont pas là il ya eu
ce coup d'arrêt alors hebri la talent
vient de dire que l'objectif des 8 10
millions est toujours là pour avril donc
on continue avec ces chiffres même si on
sait pertinemment que ça va être très
difficile à atteindre
et puis ce confinement qui montre que la
politique sanitaire est à l'arrêt depuis
des mois puisque on continue de faire
des confinement plus de 200 jours depuis
un an que les français ont vécu soit en
confinement soit sous le régime du
couvre-feu
bref un régime exceptionnel pendant un
an qui n'a jamais cessé sauf pour une
centaine de jours à peu près donc ce
virus dont on s'en débarrasse pas et ces
mesures n'ont pas permis finalement de
juguler l'épidémie
alors reste à voir quel vrai que les
nouvelles mesures dans les jours qui
viennent
réponse donc demain soir à 18 heures
merci alexis poulain d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
éditorialistes